spencer howard the rookie makes the
start tonight it's his fourth start who
was going to face the nationals last
thursday we'll finally get that chance
here tonight here is juan soto also at
360 with nine homers
swinging a miss he threw him a change up
the second change up of the at-bat and
he's got back-to-back strikeouts
here's his drubal cabrera in the cleanup
spots
swinging a miss he struck out the side
two swinging
one looking
and here's eric fetty two and two career
six games five starts against the fields
and they're all for eight against his
change up last start august 25th against
the phillies bringing up reese hoskins
the first baseman at 250s
that one's hit well deep to left field
going back out it is soto and it is gone
five home runs in his last seven games
reece hoskins has just given the films a
one-nothing lead here at the bottom of
the first inning now tom that's what you
like to see from reese's get ahead in
the count but then be aggressive while
you're ahead and account bring up bryce
harper
down and in with the slider of beauty
fetty first strikeout two down
it'll bring up jay bruce just activated
off the injured list and starting in
right field tonight
that ball's pulled deep to right field
eaton's going back he'll turn and it is
gone
into the seats for jay bruce his fifth
home run of the year the injured list
didn't quiet him
and the phillies lead it two nothing
welcome back trey turner 15-game hitting
streak coming into this game here's the
2-2
swinging a chopping ground ball up the
middle ranging gregorius behind second
throws on the run and turner beats it
out
so that'll be a 16-game hitting streak
with gregorius ranging far to his left
by the time he released it turner was
through the bag and the speed of trey
is able to extend his hitting streak
here's cabrera just one hit in his last
15 at bats there's a chance here with
two on two outs
out to the center field roman quinn
heading back a few steps from the track
makes the catch
and the side is retie
two-nothing philadelphia in the top of
the fourth outfield shades a bit to left
uneaten
at him level off and take it the other
way
adam eaton with the ball rolling toward
the chalk line a one-out double
fly ball short lefts
long running for mccutchen and he makes
the catch
[Applause]
and it's a four pitch walk the first
allowed by fedex and now jt real muto
hit again take a pin cushion that's the
fourth time rumuto has been plunked in
the last three games and so he goes down
to first base gregorio is back in the
batter's box needy struck out his first
time up
that one's toward the vacant hole on the
left side turner gets to it and it'll be
an infield hit
so the bases are loaded with no outs for
gene segura
line drive out toward left center field
on the run is soto he's not going to get
it it's going to go to the giant side
this will clear the bases as dede speeds
around third it's a three-run double for
segora he's hit it six straight now and
the phillies have opened up a
five-nothing lead
got the runner over to third now the
infield in anything hard hit
should score a run
that'll work live ball right center
field out of meeting his under tagging
from third to segura he'll score it'll
be a sac fly for baum
and the phillies needed six nothing
so the fourth straight multiple-hit game
for turner and so now you get
soto soto got a breaking ball hit it
well to left
c
u
later that's about 12 to 15
rows up and the nets are on the board as
juan soto is in double digits on home
runs
and now heath hembree
will take over for the fills this
revamped bullpen for the phillies
phillies lead at six to two michael
taylor will try his luck here against
hembree
oh michael a gets a hold of one to left
see
you
way later that'll be his third of the
year and the nets
have cut into half of the six-nothing
deficit so here's trey turner that
pitches up and so is the line drive c
u later trey turner adding a homer to
his game the nationals go back to back
first taylor and now turner home run
number seven for trey his third hit of
the night it's the phillies six in the
nationals four
hottest hitter on the planet trey turner
but trey turner doesn't get a lot of
love on the national basis and he should
here's alec
won the ball he lines it out to right
center field eaton won't get it it's
going to one hop the wall bruce read it
beautifully he's on his way to third
he'll be held there it's a double for
alec balm his fourth of the season
reece one for three tonight the home run
of the first
and a line drive down the left field
line fair it's gonna go to the corner
it's gonna score two and hoskins on his
way to second base the throw
is wide it's a stand-up two-run double
three-yard the eyes the phillies head on
it's eight to four
the nets have something going here in
the eighth inning harrison off third
eating off second
huge spot for luis garcia
out toward left center field mccutcheon
and roman quinn look at roman trying to
track it down and he does
you talked about speed he covered a lot
of ground
to reel that one in and the nationals go
scoreless in the eighth inning brandon
workman is in his sixth ball game
not a save situation but trying to seal
the deal for the fills here is juan soto
struck out swinging
walked in an opposite field two run
homer to the left in the fifth inning
juan soto
right center c
u
later philly's bullpen
two homers four rbis and this one is not
over yet
and that'll leave it up to his drupal
cabrera now the one-two pitch from
workmen
swing it a miss he got him and the ball
game is over and 24-year-old
right-hander spencer howard picks up his
first major league win